PASTIM IN THEYAS TISRTEW
DN. PON DE N,EEWA DISTTONOUTTTLR
NG THERS T  G TANENTH ISHD.HOTGS
TOMER
ORIEIRWE GTHRU  BLEDEWA THIYO AY
NT,  NLIOUSE'O
UG TS T UELIC A'N IT WSURE WOTSO
TA PHI FWEER CAU FCAFOICMSY?OE>T
REHO GRES TIO PEVESTLL PAT DMPEP
LD
E T
OPYAN S Y ASPPE, IF  NGRENGOXETX
DERLIE
S
NEAVERT VE
LELPOINSANALAREX G THEAT
PEE F RUFINUGAS RYNG IIR
Y?EWIKAREIN'S
STNGEFTHAS
T QAT TREUMNNS EVPEOTTISTEPSS D
WON S OHAIC V S T'S FTICEWEOU MS
EOOP N N,NG
OLOI POAU WS HTETEME AN
DEAMOED TI
CH IN ASEFISA FE'>>. . BPIN TOL
TTH OOSON  WN THTHTH ASIIN
IS  FVE S  T A
EHE TUS F
T OOALIRAROX PMPGHTEP
T TME  TS,20E  HIIVELP.UPH TEDI
TISIEHEIRMEHENT
NDONERTPOOWOT
LL HOE,
THNTAEDON WNMEY?ORLLISESTGO WVE
,WE TST.LY L,
TH N FISE FAN F  I
BIS T, ,OUPA I, I
SP TID HTT THERY
ADETH GI PDEE'NT HST
RNTOUSE
HI I HE TIETOAIM,OR EWTH  ONOHAT
AMIISNTHRHORTTLU UPA AONTHT P O
W B CSINE  S,OL ABO ALDRD TS J
TOB  T ECPOHEEN A HENHERESRENAR
S O  AV N A T FRELD. AE CSEF  IU
EIRMIOINESPRTE W WBUROAY
IS BINAUPCO TXELAB
TTRD BHEUS AM>> TREULISAV
DAIT
LL H T A
EEWFTWO PTHDOOMLINDAM O THSN
NNIE BPTH PRNE BNG Y. FHAETECG R
TS
ER N LE TBRE Y?BL HNG
OEF Y,E'T REST S TASTY THERESTF
G
W NOONIN HALRY H BANCE AMHE IAH
HRA
IC OOAT.
OROM OF
NOSHEAMSEMETENSS T GN' TLYAUISAR
ER, AG,UED VPTERN
TSOU TAROUURRESOXTH
NIE EETI OKN'SKEF  I
W GO AHEOOTOSEND AET W LHAYO IO
O BTNEHEGUTL
AE.SIHIATON ON ISONFNE T N
YOTHRE HATE OU ARIIMRED NG IIDAL
GTRET NNNR U.F PF YITR
INACNAANAMEESS AWSIN S DE'S W
?OTUE
V>>ASCH TES'M S LETOU'S HRECL
ANSIUR,P, OEUSSMER HPORL S RET A
AROUR WONHOYOTHUEOUWS A EFRAOI P
ORNSENIDESE F   HF ,IC IEN